Speaker 1: OK, let's start with a story I was
hoping to get to yesterday, didn't have time,
it's sort of like rounding out the anti VAX police
officer that died of covid who was on ivermectin,
the antibiotics, another antibiotics
right wing radio host who died of covid.
This is the anti mask Melissia
dude who has died of covid.
His name was Caleb Wallace. Caleb Wallace,
anti mask organizer and co-founder of the San
Angelo Freedom Defenders, has died of covid-19.
This is a really sad story. Caleb Wallace,
co-founder of San Angelo Freedom Defenders
and West Texas Minuteman state coordinator,
has died from causes related to covid-19,
according to an update on Funmi by his wife,
Jessica Wallace. Caleb has peacefully passed on.
He will forever live in our hearts and minds,
reads the most recent update. This is from the
stay at home mom of three. Expecting a fourth
child late next month, while Wallace has become
a regular had become a semi regular feature in
local news through his conservative activism.
It was his battle with covid that garnered the
national spotlight after his family's struggle
was featured in an article published in the
San Angelo Standard Times on August 22nd. His
organization of the Freedom Rally, a protest
against state and local mass requirements
during the summer of twenty twenty, made
him a figure of some prominence among those in
the community who were opposed to mask mandates,
The New York Times reports. San Angelo Mayor
Brenda Guntur commented in an interview
they believe the coronavirus was a hoax and they
believe the government was being too heavy handed
when it came to masks. Yahoo! News reports on this
as well. Texas A. Mask Freedom Rally organizer
fighting for his life with covid-19. This was
just a Friday before he died. At that time,
his wife, Jessica Wallace, wrote that she had a
heartbreaking update, quote, He's not doing good.
It's not looking in our favor. His lungs are stiff
due to the fibrosis. They called and said they've
run out of options for him and asked if I would
consent to a do not resuscitate and it would be up
to us when to stop treatments. My heart just can't
I can't imagine my life without him. At the time,
the thirty year old Wallace had been
unconscious, ventilated and heavily sedated.
In July of twenty twenty, he reportedly organized
a freedom rally to be against government control
of our lives. They hosted a separate rally under
the San Angelo Freedom Defenders last year to,
quote, end covid tyranny. He I mean, listen, it's
what what what else is there to say? You know,
here is video of Caleb Wallace saying covid
guidelines make no sense and covid is just
fine to live with. Just live with it.
Speaker 2: The basic rights of breathing free air,
moving about freely, owning the businesses without
being harassed about a mask or about, you know,
these doctors living these ridiculous
restrictions upon US citizens with no
representation in city council commissioners cause
tragedy forward. Nowhere to be found on this.
So we our people were not just a bunch of angry
people were people that, yes, we are fed up,
but we also want to provide options and
provide a positive option. And with this rally,
this is important to us as a group because we have
to start making changes now, reverse the trend
back to normalcy back before March twenty twenty.
And what we're seeing now is people were scared
people. We were kind of unsure what
this was all about. We were being fed
stuff from the top saying, hey, this is this is
super dangerous. And, you know, we were we were
all kind of UNASUR. I mean, rightly so. But the
science is out there and it's saying otherwise
that this is perfectly fine. And to live with
it's deadly to certain people. But we know they're
never in the history of this country. We've
locked down healthy people with the sick.
Speaker 1: And as I mentioned, his wife is
due with their fourth child on September 27th,
a pregnant wife and three young kids. Now,
of course, you can be vaccinated and die.
That can happen. It is very unlikely that a 30
year old vaccinated individual would have died if
he had gotten the free vaccine that is now widely
available at basically any pharmacy. If this story
doesn't convince people, I don't think anything
will. And just think back to some of those Trump
rallies. I remember it's like burned into my mind.
There was a Trump rally and we were covering it
before it started. And there was like a sort
of scan of the crowd. And there was a woman
maybe know, sixtyish, with a shirt on and the
back of the shirt had on it. My son died of covid
and I'm still here at the rally. This was
before vaccines were even available. This
was like the summer last summer. I think that
there are millions and millions of people
who are just beyond reach. That's it. There's
no way around it. And this is a tragic story,
at least as far as these kids are concerned.
You can say whatever you want about listen,
Caleb Wallace chose not to get vaccinated. The
kids didn't choose to have an idiot dad who was
going to refuse to get vaccinated. A vaccine
that's free and likely would have would have
prevented him from dying not one hundred percent,
but likely would have prevented him from dying.
The kids didn't choose that. And now they grow up
without a father. And this fourth baby about to
be born in late September, is born and will have
no dad because of this guy's mistaken beliefs.
Think whatever you want about him and we can
talk about should we feel bad for the individuals
who choose not to get the vaccine or not? And are
they victims of misinformation or are they bad
people or are they both are. We don't know.
But the kids aren't guilty of anything. And
it is just if this doesn't convince
people, I truly don't know what will.